there are monsters that are hiding in
every corner of the monster verse b-day
titans or lesser creatures animals that
seem to be of different reality but
still evolved the same way as any other
living being on the planet some of these
monsters don't even go along with a
normal plan animal classification what
are a bit of both all around the world
are these titans seen but not as diverse
as the ones of Skull Island in Skull
Island isolated from any solid continent
creatures here are left to evolve
independent of others and mutations
occur that make them into the most
strange-looking animals seen by the
naked eye many of these creatures
haven't reached are not meant to reach
the status of Titan but are still bigger
than any other animal in the world
coming up is the list of creatures and
monsters in the monster verse Skull
Island calm calm was named by the ebee
natives of Skull Island the name also
corresponds to the name of Kongo an
African country known for its population
of gorillas the Apes that come greatly
resembles standing over a hundred four
feet tall or thirty 1.7 meters the Beast
he calls Kong is a primate of such size
and ferocity that his very existence
rewrites every chapter of evolutionary
theory more mountain than mammal
he walks upright on two legs his
towering forms shaking the ground with
each thunderous step it is hard to see
how long Kong has existed but initial
analysis of bone structure and teeth
suggests that the creature is an
adolescent he is still growing Kong is
similar to Godzilla in several ways both
are the last of their kind both have a
vendetta against their natural enemies
the skull crawlers and the Muto's who
have killed the rest of their species
and both are portrayed as morally
neutral apex predators who maintain
order and have no personal quarrel with
humans
skull crawlers skull crawlers got their
name from the skull like heads and the
crawling locomotion skull crawlers a
large reptilian creatures would only too
long for limbs and no hind limbs as well
as long prehensile serpent isle tails
they have long and slender yet muscular
sturdy bodies several aspects of their
appearance are notice
skeletal particularly their torsos and
their hands small skull crawls are
easily distinguishable from large ones
their heads are smaller and more slope
they also possess a more prominently
brown skin tone largest skull crawlers
are larger and almost as big as Kong the
small ones range from 12 to 40 feet long
while the big one is 60 to 70 feet tall
and almost 200 feet long
Myers quits the mile squid seemingly
gets its name from its environment as my
refers to a stretch of swampy and boggy
ground the same areas they tend to
inhabit they are ambush predators that
lurk in the waters of Skull Island for
unsuspecting prey despite their great
strength and endurance
myah squids have limited durability as
calm was able to effin crush the head of
one with his foot resulting in its death
this creature is as long as Kong's
height between 90 and 110 feet mother
longlegs mother longlegs name is based
on the famous term daddy longlegs
a common name for various types of
insects and arachnids the mother prefix
refers to the species as female only the
mother longlegs a gigantic spider like
creatures that start around five to
seven meters tall and they possess
incredibly long legs that resemble
bamboo stalks allowing them to blend in
seamlessly with the surrounding forests
with their legs posing as plants and
their upper bodies held high above the
canopy be the top half of the model long
legs are covered in leaves with a red
eyes in addition to their eight legs
mother longlegs possess two additional
limbs located close to their heads which
are equipped with binson like claws
psycho vultures the name psycho vulture
comes from a mix of psycho estate they
go into upon ingesting sudden poisonous
puffer fish and vulture which is a
reference to their avian form while
their subspecies leaf wing comes from
their wing design which is both green
and shaped much like a leaf which is
multiplied by the veins running through
their wings psycho vultures are grey
large back light creatures possessing a
wide wingspan and snap no skulls
leaf wings are smaller motor
like creatures that are about the same
size as adult humans they are green in
color with yellow heads orange wings and
long spear like snouts covered with
jagged edges scurvy buffaloes the name
of the creature specifically in
scientific nomenclature is potentially
derived from a scary which is a small
rocky island which tend to be home to
moss and grasses scare buffaloes greatly
resembled abnormally large water
buffalos but with several differences
they possess incredibly large horns that
have forked into at least three branches
the scare buffalo is a super biological
bullet that is largely amphibious in its
grazing patterns initially phylogenetic
studies show DNA ancestry with the Asian
water buffalo inhabiting lakes and Mario
systems the skirt buffaloes is equipped
with a remarkably evolutionary advantage
the Beast is back and flanks are fused
with hearty bone structures and dense
green foliage this creatures of flora
fauna of Skull Island spore mantises
spore mantises resemble a stick insect
al-bayt one so big it instead mimics a
fall in law they have six wood shaped
legs and bark like the skin covering
their bodies and their head is small and
retractable into the log like covering a
gigantic precursor to the fast motor
deer order the spore mantis is in
essence a stick insect the size of a
mature redwood tree the limbs of its box
skin body house powerful muscle systems
that is a unique interweaving of
straight attendants and fibrous
structural tissues more commonly found
in the stems and roots of trees these
appendages allow the spore Mantis to
scuttle across ground at an alarming
speed
biggest bow mantises reached lengths of
up to 15 meters or 50 feet long death
jackals deaths jackals also known as
spiny mortem a reptilian kaiju that
first appeared in the most of us Comics
Skull Island the birth of Kong death
jackals resemble a cross between lush
dromaeosaurus and hyenas with long limbs
and hairy spikes they have long snout of
reptilian faces and are spiky main
running down the back of them
it is unclear if they are primarily
bipedal or quadrupedal as many
individuals are seen missing some limbs
with the agility of a leopard and a bite
power of a great white shark the death
jackal is one of the most hybrid
energetic creatures of the island the
creatures - partly exoskeletal
sharpening into a mane of spike fibers
that are as sharp as razor wires
existing in a constant state of rabid
ferocity it will devour its own kind and
even itself if a kill is hard to come by
a deaths jackal size is close to large
Raptor species ranging from 6 to 12 feet
long siren jaws siren jaws also known as
gigantis crocodilian are giant reptilian
kaijin at first appeared in the most of
us Comics Skull Island the birth of Kong
the siren jaw is an ambush predator that
lies in wait for any potential prey to
land on its island like back the siren
jaw is a mass of crocodilian like
creature covered in clan life with small
orange eyes and large jaws filled with
razor-sharp teeth when submerged in
water
the creature greatly resembles an island
the siren jaw is a colossal crocodilian
predator indigenous to the lakes and
tributaries of the southern jungle it's
hybrid physiology exhibits some of the
most extreme examples of flora fauna has
yet seen as it matures the siren jaw
goes into a pubescent stage in which a
small nursery of deciduous trees grow on
its rocky back the size of this siren
jock reaches ranges from 45 to 65 feet
long
swamp okis lying beneath the surface of
the swamp lands to the east of the
island the submergent insectoids extend
their woody limbs above the surface
making them indistinguishable from the
abundant wealth and foliage surrounding
it suam locals also known as stagnant
acridity are insect guided at first
appeared in the most of us coming Skull
Island the birth of gone swamp locusts
resemble large water names will lamprey
like mouth and tiger fish like teeth
magma turtles magma terrace also known
as Tortosa volcana a giant turtle Kaiji
that first appeared in most of us comics
Skull Island the birth of Kong magma
turtles are gigantic tails will rock
like shells and tree is sprouting from
them indigenous to the volcanic shelf
around the base of Hell spring break
these gigantic turtles appear to be born
from eggs hatch in the heart of the
volcano as the modern rock heats and
cracks the shell layer magma engulfs the
embryonic life-form hardening into a
resilient stone shell these creatures
are 30 to 40 feet tall vine Stranglers
vine strangles also known as Vitus
strangle re are giant insect guided and
live on Skull Island vine strangles are
named for the vine like appearances and
their behavior of strangling their
victims to death when Stranglers are
Lodge get it a stick insect like
creatures whose bodies have evolved
closely to resemble tree branches and
vines the holy tiger the icarus tigress
is a monster originally intended to
appear in the 2017 most of us film calm
Skull Island
however it does appear in the film's
Chinese marketing the monarch files 2.0
featured on home video release a hoary
tiger resembles a giant Siberian tiger
though white in color reddish black
stripes run throughout the Tigers body
and his face is tinted bright red it
also contains a pair of baelish blue
eyes most notably they adorn an
impressive pair of stack like antlers on
top of their heads so anyway this brings
us to the end of the list and do like
share and subscribe for more kaiju and
most related content and do check out
our other videos as well